in meinem ersten fall geht es um
jennifer schützer das ist eine
hotelfachfrau und sie wollte umziehen
von lübeck nach kiel und wollte ihren
telefon und internet vertrag auch mit in
ihre neue wohnung nehmen
sie hat sich dann bei vodafone gemeldet
um ihre daten umzumelden ihre neue
adresse anzumelden und denen eben
bescheid zu sagen dass diese tänze
technik eben jetzt an einem anderen ort
sein muss
vodafone hatte ihr auch diese umstellung
zugesagt und hatte erst gesagt dass das
alles funktionieren wird allerdings
bekam sie dann nach ein paar wochen die
e mail dass es technische gründe
technisch aus technischen gründen könnte
es kein internet in der neuen wohnung
geben also die könnten ihres internet
dort nicht stellen
man muss bei vodafone dazu sagen wo
davon hat wenn es um telefonverträge
geht immer eine kombi aus telefon und
internet verträgen
dementsprechend hat sich frau die
schützer dann überlegt dass sie sich
eben einen neuen anbieter sucht und hat
dann auch die zahlungen zu vodafone
eingestellt nach einem jahr bekamen sie
dann plötzlich post von einem
inkassounternehmen und sollte 531 euro
bezahlen weil sie eben die zahlungen
eingestellt hatte ein neuer vertrag
sowohl davon hatte für sie einen neuen
vertrag angelegt anstatt die adresse
einfach zu ändern
ja und frau die schützer war natürlich
total verzweifelt weil 531 euro war
natürlich sowieso schon viel geld und
sie hatte er zeitgleich auch schon einen
neuen vertrag und hat sich dann ein bild
kämpft gewandt und wir lernen sie jetzt
kennen hallo frau die schützer und auch
dabei ahnt campions unser rechtsanwalt
hallo in die runde
hallo da bedienen das ist ja wirklich
wahnsinnig da denken sie dass die
kriegen das nicht hin sie schließen
einen neuen vertrag ab und dann kommt da
noch so eine ärgerliche inkasso post wie
haben sie das denn aufgenommen
vorbesitzer ja also erstmal nachricht
natürlich versucht über alle wege alle
zu kontaktieren telefonisch oder per e
mail und hat mich öfter an das
inkassounternehmen gewandt und der in
die lage so geschildert wie ich es bei
ihnen auch getan habe na ja und da kam
aber nie was zurück also keiner konnte
mir helfen und öfters im costa bei
vodafone wurde wird versichert dass das
ja gar nicht ging also wie das gelaufen
ist und dass das alles rückwirkend
geändert wird
und ich mein geld zurück bekommt das ist
aber nie passiert das ist ja echt warten
und da waren sie so verzweifelt da haben
sie sich an uns gewandt
ich muss mal den anwalt hat zu fragen
also tatsächlich hier geht es um
wirklich wirklich übelsten musik
mobilfunk ärger an kämpfen sie haben
jetzt genau zugehört dann wird einem
gesagt wir können bei ihnen nichts
anbieten und trotzdem werden an
forderungen geltend gemacht das geht
doch nicht oder
also machen wir sind fassungslos vor
allen dingen werden ja hier offenbar
vereinbaren die erst getroffen wurden
werden ja gebrochen beziehungsweise
nicht eingehalten ist natürlich total
ärgerlich das hören wir in der praxis
immer immer wieder da kann ich wirklich
nur empfehlen wenn es so am telefon
vereinbarungen gibt über das vorgehen
beispielsweise vertrag gekündigt neuen
vertrag und man hat irgendwie mit dem
telekommunikationsunternehmen etwas
vereinbart dann bitte das immer sofort
selbst per e-mail bestätigen
dann hat man hinterher zumindest etwas
in der hand es ist tatsächlich so dass
oft die eine hand nicht was die andere
macht und sie haben sich dann foulte
schützer dann an uns gewandt und was
konnten wir für sie erreichen
eigentlich hab mindestanteil von knapp
200 euro habe ich wieder bekommen 390
euro hatte ich bereits überwiesen
geratet ihr jetzt eigentlich gewesen
wäre von 240 euro die ist mir auch
erspart geblieben
sie lachen das wollen wir natürlich auch
in dieser sendung sind sie denn jetzt
rundum glücklich dass sie dieses problem
jetzt wirklich von der backe haben